hey YouTube
it's been a little while
uh we need to talk
[Music]
so yeah despite it being kind of its own
sub genre here on YouTube YouTubers
complaining about YouTube I haven't done
it in a little bit
because
there's nothing new to complain about
it's the same nonsense it's been for a
while
but then
I noticed something different
something odd
I think that maybe others have noticed
nobody in the circle's eye traffic with
has talked about it if they have
so I'm going to talk about it regardless
and if this turns out to already be a
well-known thing well
yeah I'm just the fool then I guess but
um
YouTube's messing with monetization
now that in and of itself is uh hardly
news we all remember the adpocalypse a
few years back but it's not that it's
actually something that
on paper
they could probably
defend or at least they'd have a much
better chance at defending than you know
when they demonetize specific videos
without sending you any kind of
notification about it you have to go in
and check manually to see if something
has had been marked as not Advertiser
friendly and it runs with limited ads or
with no ads because because of the
subject matter etc etc etc like I'm not
talking about any of that
they're putting in more ads
now I'll get into the specifics of what
I'm talking about in a minute but that
again in and of itself by itself if
you've been paying attention to YouTube
that's not a shock either
YouTube thrives on the ad Revenue
that's also what the creators who do
this professionally thrive on well it's
part of what they thrive on pretty much
all of us have patreons for a reason go
support mine cause
damn the site but
yeah I wonder how this is going to do in
the algorithm it tanked I wonder why
anyway
um the thing is YouTube has done various
small things to just signal that
they're going to be doing something
you know whether it be the fact that uh
back in I believe it was 2020 they
shortened how long a video has to be to
run a mid-roll ad a mid-roll to be clear
uh because this is going to kind of be
the big Crux of what I'm going to talk
about a mid-roll is uh any AD that runs
during the body of the video
and it used to be your video had to be
at least 10 minutes long to have access
to the option to place mid-rolls and if
it was any shorter than that they
wouldn't let you well they shortened it
to just eight minutes
so if you've ever watched videos from
like three or four years ago where it
seemed like they were arbitrarily
hitting like 10 minutes and a second
especially if it was from a Content Mill
style Channel yeah there's a reason and
most of them now are probably aiming
right for that eight minute Mark but
that happened last September they
actually ran an experiment basically
appearing to stress test the audience to
find out how far they could push
maximizing ads some people were
reporting getting 10 ads in a row in the
pre-roll normally at this point it's two
Max and people were reporting an
increased number of unskippable ads
people were reporting more mid-rolls
than they were used to and this was
fairly brief and YouTube did acknowledge
that this was something they did this
wasn't a glitch this wasn't a mistake it
wasn't an error this was something they
did deliberately and then stopped doing
because they'd gathered whatever data
they wanted
but we all should have known at that
point that they were going to try and do
something
because
you wouldn't gather that data if you
don't plan to use it and of course they
pushed harder during the experimentation
period than they would on any kind of
actual implementation
the thing is we didn't know what they
were going to do
and while there might be other things
coming down the pipe
what they appear to have done and what I
seem to have uncovered uh and again I'm
not trying to act like an investigative
journalist other people might have known
or even talked about this uh Hey
YouTubers
they're messing with your mid-rolls
because here's the thing about mid-roll
ads
you can have them placed in one of two
ways
you can press a button and YouTube's
algorithm will place mid-rolls
automatically I do not recommend ever
making use of that because it's going to
place them haphazardly basically
anywhere where there's a little bit of a
pause well not necessarily anywhere but
spaces with a little bit of a pause it's
going to consider viable sometimes that
pause is there because yes you're taking
a breather before shifting to another
topic or it's a title card for a new
subject if it's a video essay but also
sometimes you pause because you took a
second to gather your thoughts or you
just paused for emphasis and suddenly an
ad plays never use the automatic the
automatic is terrible I manually place
my ads I always have and
um this is important
to note now so a little bit of backstory
as to why I started looking into this
um I have a tendency to binge certain
YouTubers off and on
um and oftentimes re-watching stuff like
just to have his background like I'm
doing something else I'm doing chores
I'm doing laundry I'm you know I'm
packing for the for the weekend you know
going to to see somebody or you know
whatever and I've I've got stuff on in
the background that's stuff I already
kind of know but I like
and my most recent
um sort of re-watch well re-listen
really because I don't really watch it
that much but re-listen uh kick has been
taught in the shadows who is a YouTuber
I've enjoyed for a while I I like his
stuff a lot and I noticed
his videos kept getting interrupted with
ads
and not once
but repeatedly
and I didn't remember his videos having
repeated monetization
uh more than one mid-roll on most of
them like some of them maybe like maybe
some of the list videos but not on his
standard ones
and it seemed excessive and it jumped
out of me I'm like
did did he add extra monetization like
some of his older stuff because some of
the stuff I was listening to was years
old
and it just struck me it's like this
seems like a lot and then I just thought
in general like you know I kind of have
been feeling like more videos that from
people who you know I like have more
often awkwardly inserted ads
and then on a hunch I decided to look at
my own videos
my own monetization
my own minerals
here's what I found firstly just
standard practice for me I place a
pre-roll a post role and if a video is
long enough and I feel it's appropriate
I will place mid-rolls sometimes I
actually don't place mid-rolls at all
and I'll come back to that as well but I
first of all I found somewhere either
the pre-roll or the post roll or both
were turned off
the mid-rolls were never turned off on
on these older videos that I was looking
at
but then when I went to look at the
mid-roll the placement was definitely
not what I would have done we're going
to take this video as a recent example
for where I tend to place them this is a
solid enough example because it's pretty
standard for what I tend to do so this
video in particular was about 21 minutes
I had an ad placed uh around 8 20 and
around 4 28. now just going by time I
would have broken them up a little bit
closer to like the seven minute and the
14 minute Mark so like
you know sort of at third points uh
through it
this was a list video so I had to place
them in a way that actually fell between
entries if I'd done it just by the
timing it would have interrupted the mid
entry but that gives you a general idea
of the general philosophy in which I
approached this my general approach is
to place a a an ad
maybe every 8 to 12 minutes depending on
length it's actually pretty rare for me
to place more than two ads regardless of
length that's usually where I top out
occasionally if the video is up in the
40 minute range maybe I'll play three
but I don't always do that two is pretty
standard since these days most my videos
run between 20 minutes and half an hour
so two is pretty normal but sometimes I
only do one but anyway that's what it
tends to look like and that's how I've
always done it because I've never gone
for the automatic mineral placement I've
always placed them manually because I
don't trust YouTube system and I'll even
give you an idea of how bad it can get
because
something that was actually brought to
my attention by some people who because
I every two weeks I do live streams on
here and some folks who miss the live
stream but we're trying to watch the
playback somebody this was like three
years ago or so somebody told me this
thing is loaded with ads I was like what
and I went and to check the mid-rolls on
the live stream now admittedly
um at the time I had just let the
automatic placement do the mid-rolls for
me and they looked like this
which is absurd
now these days after uh it tries to
place those on the archive live streams
I then go in and manually delete usually
all but three or four of them
um but yeah that's how bad it can get on
the automatic I think it's probably a
little bit worse on lives than on the
regular ones but that's the Baseline for
how bad it can get it's why don't you
use the automatic placement as a rule of
thumb
I do kind of use it a little bit in the
lives and so far as I'll let it place
them initially but then as soon as
they're placed I'll go in and delete
most of them anyways it hasn't been that
bad on the ones where clearly stuff has
been altered but it has been stuff like
this I would never place an ad a minute
and 30 seconds into a video
especially a video like this one was
talking about representation and build
pots like maybe at some earlier point in
my career I might have placed an ad
between a preamble and like the first
entry on a ranked list or something but
that's not what kind of video this was I
wouldn't place an ad there and there's
others we've got one here ad dropped at
12 seconds
I would never place an ad at 12 seconds
yet there it is and initially I thought
this was only afflicting older videos
but then there's stuff like this which
is only like a month and a bit old and
it's got an ad just a little over a
minute into it I didn't put that there
so what's it doing there YouTube
now this might strike you as odd
that I am complaining about this
because
doesn't that mean more ad revenue for me
possibly
but it also is disrespectful to my
audience because I didn't put it there
because I know it would be disruptive to
be there and it's disrespectful to me as
a creator
I didn't tell you to place them
automatically I put them where I think
they belong and then there was something
else I noticed that isn't necessarily
Insidious but very much shows the
mentality
that YouTube is currently operating
under which is on my the main page of my
dashboard there's this little bit here
and it was giving me the idea and like
showing me coins like oh look money
money uh enable ads on your latest video
now it's specifically citing my video on
trans genocide in the US first of all
not my latest video it is my most
successful video of this year so far by
a bit but I deliberately chose not to
have mid-rolls run on that video because
given the subject matter it would have
been gross
I did have the pre-roll in the post roll
on there because yes I do still need to
kind of make a living to some degree but
I was not going to interrupt the body of
that video with a mid-roll ad because I
did not need my discussion of what is
happening to trans people in this
country to be interrupted by an ad for
freaking Bounty paper towels or whatever
the hell
I didn't put them there for a reason
now
YouTube has not gone so far as to turn
on mid-rolls on a video where I
deliberately didn't have them but they
have messed around with the mid-roll
placement on other videos and they're
dropping very blatant hints basically
telling me uh we think you we think you
made a mistake this video is doing so
well clearly there should be ads running
in the body but maybe I don't want them
there
maybe I
as a creator
felt that something was more important
than the money lining my pocket and
definitely more important than the money
lining yours
so again it might strike you as odd
because don't I want to make money yes
but I also want to respect my audience
and I know YouTube doesn't respect and
YouTube doesn't respect any creator
they don't they respect the potential
for ads that's why they shorten the
length of a video to be able to get
mid-rolls that's why they stress tested
the limits of people's ability to take
in advertisements and then there's other
little things like there was a thing a
little bit ago where when a mid-roll is
coming up a little countdown timer you
know five four three two ad coming that
stops showing up on some instances on
some platforms now they claim that was a
glitch and that's possible since it was
primarily uh happening to those viewing
on TVs as opposed to those viewing on
phones or on their PCS
but also might not have been
given that that's how regular TV is
granted you know shows are structured to
allow for ads at a certain point but you
don't get a countdown when you watch TV
so I could just as easily believe that
they made a deliberate choice to try and
get away with not having that warning
coming up on things played on a TV
because of a presumed difference in
tolerance of the audience watching by
that method
that's purely speculative on my part but
it would fit what they've been doing and
something I found out while editing this
uh YouTube is currently running another
experiment and this one where they won't
play certain videos if you have an ad
blocker enabled so not only are they
currently trying to jam more ads in they
are going to force people to watch them
in any way they possibly can and this is
all very standard by the way because
companies are expected to grow year over
year and if they hit a point where they
can no longer expect that they can grow
their customer base at least not at the
rate they have been well then their best
option from their perspective is to milk
more money out of customers they already
have it's why Netflix is cracking down
on password sharing it's why video game
makers Jam in as much monetization as
Their audience will let them get away
with because it's no longer simply
acceptable to make profits you must make
more profits than last year and you must
do that every year into Infinity but
every business has a natural ceiling
where it will level out and you're not
going to get any more customers than you
currently have you're still making
profit but you're not growing well now
it's time to squeeze blood from a stone
welcome to capitalism
so what can be done well first of all
does anyone else even get mad about this
I have no idea the viewers might
because it wrecks your experience to
have ads placed not only excessively but
in spots where it completely breaks the
flow of the video so it's harming your
experience as a viewer but YouTube
ultimately doesn't really care about you
it doesn't really care about creators
either but it cares slightly more about
us
than it does about you
so what can creators do well first of
all it's a question of how many of them
even care because a lot of them are
going to go more money what's the
problem
dignity
respect
coherence
the appreciation of the actual flow of
the art of presenting your work to the
world
and if that doesn't matter to you then
while we have completely different ideas
of what the purpose of being on a
platform like this is and I have nothing
to say to you but if you are a Creator
at all first of all actually I would
encourage you to check your own videos
because while I am very confident in
what I'm saying that this is what's
happening is happening deliberately I am
currently a sample size of one
so first of all if you yourself are a
Creator and you're monetized I would
highly encourage you to look into this
yourself and see what you find and if
you find what I found and keep in mind
it's not every video so don't just look
at a couple and go like that's not
happening I had to dig around and like I
said initially I thought it was only on
older videos because I was finding it
more there but then I found it on newer
stuff too so it's not on everything I
couldn't figure out a pattern where it's
popping up but it's definitely there
and if that bothers you for any of the
reasons that it bothers me or indeed for
reasons other than that if that bothers
you at all
say something
because
this for us is not YouTube making us
more money it's them exerting control
over what we put out there it's them
robbing us of our ability to say how
monetization works on our own work
that's one of the few bits of power we
have in this relationship is deciding
whether or not to monetize and how to
monetize
and I have no doubt they want to place
more ads because they're getting rid of
the overlay ad that went away just a
month ago or so
now granted it probably wasn't making
them that much money it really only
happened on PCS but that's still a loss
that's still ads that aren't running
anymore
they want to make up for that and that
was probably an easy thing to cut
because nobody liked the overlay ads you
have to x out of them they're taking up
a portion of the screen it probably
could even be pitched as a Improvement
for the consumer
while they start to mess with the
creators in a way that also
wrecks the experience for consumers
I want to know how widespread this is
and it would be really heartening to
know I'm not the only one who's actually
pretty upset about this
YouTube
you have a lot of power in this scenario
already you basically hold almost all
the cards when it comes to whether or
not we make money how much money we make
the ability to place the ads and trust
that they were there in the manner that
we decided was one of the few things
that was in our own hands
the idea that you would take it away and
behind our backs because I don't
remember any notification telling me
that this was coming
[__]
is what this is big heaping piles of
capitalists
and I had to talk about it
I would encourage you to spread this
around as I said people complain about
it's about the only ammunition we've got
and people have to care and maybe nobody
does but me I don't know
this video will probably tank in the
algorithm anyway
I wonder why
what are your thoughts about this have
you come across the same thing whatever
your thoughts are anecdotal or
statistically backed up drop them down
in the comments let's talk about it
patreon pays the bills a lot more
consistently than YouTube does so if you
care about what I do that's the best way
to ensure that I can keep doing it
especially with this freaking platform
but even if you can't do this like
subscribe and share
I do think that if this is as
underreported as I as it feels this
might be worth sharing around I don't
know maybe it's not
in any case regardless of my level of
anger
what I want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla Gourley and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]
yeah
yeah despite it being kind of its own
shop
Mish Monte penny